[Music]
she's the only person i want to hang out
with
like she is my best friend i just want
to be with her all the time
ellen degeneres and porsha de rossi have
been smitten since meeting in 2004.
they married four years later and have
been together through thick and thin
from the talk show host receiving the
presidential medal of freedom
to her facing accusations of workplace
toxicity
on set of the ellen show as you may have
heard this summer there were allegations
of a toxic work environment at our show
in february ellen told people magazine
she wouldn't have made it without her
wife's support
quote it was a horrible time in my life
and she was a rock
she kept me going and tried to help me
put things in perspective
canadian born david furnish has been in
elton john's world since 1993.
the rocket man popped the question 12
years later when same-sex civil
partnerships were made legal in england
where they live
in 2014 when same-sex marriage became
legal in the uk
they converted their union into a
marriage they've had two sons along the
way
and still managed to celebrate all of
life's special moments
so last month elton turned 74 what did
you do for him
and have you already started to plan for
the 75th birthday bash
just having the family together is the
nicest thing of all
75th to be honest with you i haven't
even thought about it and you really
need to start thinking about it i know
it's you know i don't mean to be but
at the moment it's hard to plan one week
in advance
is this your official coming out and i
was like coming out from where
opening up last august to gma about her
new marriage to singer jessica betts
emmy nominated actress nissi nash says
it was love
at first sight so i'm in my husband's
studio
it came as a surprise to some just five
months prior neezy had finalized her
divorce
from husband jay tucker but leading up
to the official split
she told et the pair remained friendly
we love each other
the love is just taken on a different
form but that's always going to be my
friend
and canada's most recognizable trans
youtuber
gigi gorgeous began dating nats getty
back in 2016
before tying the knot in a lavish
ceremony three years later
and opening up to us about her special
day
i wish i could do it all over again like
i never really thought that i would get
married but
now that i am it just feels really right
what surprised me the most about married
life is nothing has changed
it's just a title that makes me feel
more secure in my relationship
non-binary queer eye star jonathan van
ness surprised fans in january
after revealing he secretly got hitched
last summer
he says on instagram he met husband mark
peacock while on a comedy tour in london
since then mark has made the hop across
the pond even getting his us green card
and we can't forget about ricky martin
the pop icon is now happily married to
artist ron joseph and opened up to us
about family life with their poor kids
during lockdown
we're a lot and we're loud and we're
latinos so yeah there's no
no time for sadness there's no time for
it to just kind of
we just gotta be there available for the
kids and and
for each other it's it's been very
interesting like for all of us
um but i i now see light at the end of
the tunnel so it's been nice